Welcome back!
We are here with the multitalented star
of "Inventing Anna," Anna Chlumsky!
Woo!
All right, you're gonna share
one of your many talents with us,
tarot card reading.
Yes, I would love to!
And you know I don't know how it works.
How does it work?
Well, what I like to do is pull a daily tarot card.
Just a daily one.
You can ask yourself, I don't know, like,
"What's today about?"
or like, "What should I know today?
What should I look out for today?
What's in my heart?
How can I serve life today?"
Anything that you wanna know for your day.
So take a deep breath.
Okay, and let it out.
Think of what a question for the day would be for you.
Can I say it out loud?
You can, if you wish.
Why not?
Will I see him again?
Okay, okay.
Ooh!
So make three piles,
thinking of your question.
Great, and now you and put 'em back together.
Great, and now I will,
I don't if you can see that.
I don't know, we did that.
That's what we did, okay?
And, yeah, keep your question in your mind
and find a card.
Okay, that's your card, turn it over.
All right, we have got eight of cups.
And what I'm gonna ask you is, what stands out?
That there is a solo hiker
on the card.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know,
do you identify with the hiker in this card?
I don't know.
I am definitely the solo hiker, I am.
And I've never entered relationships as a whole person.
So I've sort of, now that I'm kind of open
to dating again after six years,
and being a single mom and raising my kids,
and their dad is happily married,
his side of the street's like great and happy and healthy,
I'm like, "Oh, maybe."
And I'm like, I have never felt like this in my life.
So I'm very happy being the solo hiker.
I love it, I love it.
And if we turn upside down,
we can let all of that other thing you were hanging onto go.
I love that, if you turn it upside down,
you can let it all go.
'Cause the cup's holding onto stuff, right?
So let's let it go.
Thank you for this very spiritual moment.
Yeah, isn't it fun?
I love this, I love this.
So thanks for letting me do it.
Thank you for letting me
like work through this meaningful
and important stuff.
I'm happy to.
Now I'm so excited to tell you that I spent several hours
just engrossing myself,
falling in love.
First of all, hold on, "Veep."
I mean just give me...
Six Emmy nominations?
Yeah, yeah.
That must be a no psychic needed indication
you're on the right path.
Yeah, I felt that way.
I felt, yeah, a little bit.
It's a good feeling.
It's a nice feeling.
But a good peer review is a good feeling.
All right, so I have to ask you
about "Inventing Anna."
Oh my, yeah, it's wild.
Okay, so it's Shonda Rhimes
swinging hard for Netflix yet again.
It is a real two-hander with you and Julia Garner.
It is so incredible, and luscious,
and alluring, and exciting, and this crazy story!
Yeah, and it is an amazing thing
to make a show kind of in real time
when so many people are already so interested
in the story that it's based on.
It's this young woman,
for anybody who, like myself,
did not know about it before the show,
a young woman, Anna Delvey, several years ago,
figured out a way to scam her way
up into like the highest ranks of New York society,
all the glitz and glamor.
And I play the reporter who investigates her story.
I loved it, I was glued.
At finally like 11:30, I was like,
"Turn it off, go to bed, you have a big day tomorrow."
That's great.
Thank you, thank you!
So thank you so much
for sharing life,
sharing your tarot wisdom,
and also telling us about your illustrious career,
then, now, and as we cheer you on into the future.
Thank you, the future.
Be sure to watch "Inventing Anna,"
streaming now on Netflix!
Thank you.
And we'll be right back!
(upbeat music)